The Joe Rogan Experience people are so
nuts with attention do you hear about
that one guy that
crashed his plane on purpose for YouTube
views yes like he jumped out of the
plane hiked like let it [__] crash
for life for views for views
I mean I guess when you're doing the
math and you think how much the direct
the deliberately crashing plane to get
YouTube views so like
this guy just jumped out of a [__]
plane
so like who knows who's kid that [__]
plane is gonna slam into yeah imagine
you're hiking with your family this is
amazing beautiful mountains and you get
hit in the face by a plane
buy a plane that was like flown by a
YouTube influencer why would I mean he
just ruined that plane too
well I think the calculation is he knows
the number of views he's gonna get on
YouTube will generate more money than
the plane was worth so there's a profit
there like whatever he paid for the
plane is probably less than what he'll
make from YouTube from that video
two
and he got video footage of the plane
crash
say the camera on the plane
it is so crazy we could do this now that
we can convert Our Lives into money it's
so crazy you could like just film
yourself doing [__] and then like maybe
make so much money off of like just
stuff that you know normal stuff so was
this guy trying to say that he the plane
crash happened with him in it was he
trying to like fake that and the hike
out is that what he's what he's doing or
did he like let people know that he
jumped out of the plane all right here
and filmed that said it was an accident
that actually happened in 2021 oh and
they just found out about the whole
investigation happened
it's cool man there's there's videos of
Pilots
watching the video and like making
commentary on why it's suspicious
because like apparently you look at the
plane and there's stuff that should be
in a plane that's not in a plane like
expensive stuff
he was acting like the engine went out
and he had to bail uh
but he also then went and knew where it
crashed and snuck back in and pulled the
wreckage out before like the fa could go
and investigate he pulled the wreckage
out yeah
he says they told him to preserve the
wreckage he said he waited two days to
report the crash
I think he had already gone and towed
out of there or something like that huh
more than two weeks after the crash he
had a friend flew a helicopter to the
crash site and airlifted the wreckage
to Ranchos his squawk in Santa Barbara
County where it was loaded onto a
trailer attached to Jacob's pickup truck
whoa It's not wild yeah he unloaded it
in a hanger he drove the wreckage to an
airport
he then cut up and destroyed the
airplane wreckage and over the course of
a few days deposited the attached parts
of the wrecked airplane into trash bins
in the airport and elsewhere
wow three million views off of that
yeah it's super normal if you just chop
in an airport or an airplane up and
putting in trash bins all over the
airport think of like your inner
dialogue is your depositing your your
plane what would you do to a body
sounds like he's due into a body yeah he
was he was just trying to like it like
hot like it's such a complex way to get
YouTube views like it's yeah it worked
though it worked but now he's gonna go
to jail yeah for maybe a long time yeah
like I think so how many years he faces
holy [__]
20 years for a stupid YouTube stuff and
a penalty of up to sixteen hundred and
forty four dollars for each day he did
not return
something I mean we do need strict
penalties for sure for to keep people
from just just like dropping planes out
of the sky on us yeah yeah you got to
set an example for a guy like that and
that guy could dude I mean who knows
where that plane was what happens if
that plane catches wind that's so wild
flies into someone's house and then the
guy's a mass murderer when they were
making YouTube in the early days I don't
think they ever thought that like there
would be plane crashes because of their
technology I don't think they ever
thought like this thing is going to like
influence right society and just destroy
lives people are going to ruin their
lives for for views on this thing
imagine that guy had a plot out where
the plane was going to crash too because
he had to be jumping high enough or you
can jump I don't know what that
threshold is but you got to be pretty
high up there where you can jump and
then film yourself before you even pull
the parachutes right so he's feeling
himself yeah I mean it was a plan like
he thought about that [__] plane is
way up there way up and that that sucker
is how long do you think he flies for it
if you really do you
that's a CR he could have killed people
he's 100 I mean the assumption is No
One's Gonna be out there but I mean
that's a huge assumption such a huge
assumption you could hit another plane
you could do there's a lot of things
that can happen yeah you're way up there
and you're bailing out while it's way up
there so it has to be up there enough
where you could jump out how how high
was it when he jumped out does it say
I'm looking for more details he said he
was trying to get a sponsorship deal
with who better help
but I could almost figure it out so I'll
just let people look that up you can
kind of guess it's
doesn't say the name of it though but
what do you mean you can kind of guess
it says it's a wallet company oh God
Jesus Christ he's trying to get a
sponsorship it's I mean this era of
capitalism is so bizarre like so bizarre
the way people are are manipulating the
system or just the what they're doing
wow just that's what I love regardless
of how also you have to like ethics
aside
whoa yeah that is badass like pull away
the ethics just look at like purely
what you not only did you like fly your
plane in this guy jump out of it but
yeah he represented the United States
and snowboarding the 2014 Winter
Olympics he's an Olympian whoa and then
he like put himself in the worst
situation and managed to hike out and
then
like monetize it dispose of the plane he
has a friend with a helicopter who was
like yeah sure I'll get your wreckage
[__] man that's like pull the ethics out
and it's like what a fascinating rotten
dude right like yeah right wow he's got
a friend with a helicopter that pulled
plane wreckage out of the mountains
like those are that's you that's how you
know you got a friend
yeah well you pay him a lot right
because like was what he was doing
illegal
okay you do there's probably some rules
like if you have to report a plane crash
you can't just like take the wreckage I
imagine there's enough like ways you
could talk your way out of that one
really yeah I didn't know he told me he
reported it yeah I didn't know yeah
right that I'm sure yeah I mean I don't
know [__] I don't know I'm just out here
working flying my helicopter around I
don't know what's going on just picking
up a broken plane I am but a helicopter
pilot yeah yeah I I imagine the
helicopter pilot is like probably
sweating a little bit but he's probably
okay right like because they're gonna
focus on the yeah Maniac who flew his
plane into a Mountainside for YouTube
views
what a world what a world